devant le Parlement de la Géorgie ce
soir une solidarité sans borne des
milliers de personnes sous le drapeau
j'en ai bleu de la compassion pure et
simple
nous les Géorgiens s'avancent que c'est
que d'être envahi par la Russie dit Maya
les discours nourris d'applaudissements
et de rage à l'endroit de leur propre
gouvernement qui n'en fait pas assez
pour l'Ukraine du Maya
et même se rapproche de la Russie
il y a parmi la foule des Russes
beaucoup de Russes qui ont fui leur pays
comme artium fier de pouvoir enfin
exprimer haut et fort son soutien au
peuple de l'Ukraine
Pavel un autre russe en exil dit qu'il
partage leur peur et leur combat
ce refrain ce champ patriotique qui est
devenu dans le monde entier un hymne
pour la victoire de l'Ukraine retentit
aujourd'hui dans les grandes capitales
du monde
au Pays-Bas en Grèce
à Varsovie des sirènes comme celle qui
réveille les Ukrainiens jour et nuit ont
raisonné dans ce quartier de
l'ambassadeur russe
[Musique]
éclatant la carcasse d'un chat russe qui
a envahit l'Ukraine le canon pointait
directement vers l'ambassade de la
Russie
à Moscou les quelques courageux qui ont
osé afficher leur soutien aux frères
slaves ont été arrêtés sur le champ
ion
il ne nous représente pas à tenue à dire
artium dans sa ville d'adoption
tibilissi dans un pays où la notion de
liberté n'est jamais tenue pour acquis
et se transmet de génération en
génération
pourrait pour eux ce premier
anniversaire n'est pas celui de la
guerre mais une célébration de la
résistance ukrainienne ici Tamara
Alteresco Radio-Canada à tibilissi